monsieur sarkozy est le plus jeune élu
politique que nous ayons jamais invité à
l'heure de vérité vous fêterez en effet
vos 37 ans après demain mardi
alors je rappelle que vous êtes avocat
au barreau de paris que vous êtes maire
de neuilly depuis maintenant presque dix
ans et que vous êtes député du
département le plus riche de france les
hauts-de-seine s l'habitude des
prétoires
toujours est il que vous avez un langage
direct qui contraste avec la langue de
bois de vos aînés mais si nous vous
avons invités aujourd'hui c'est surtout
parce que l'homme clé du dispositif
présidentiel de jacques chirac
c'est vous et s'ils entrent à jour à
l'elysée
vous serez ministre vous le serez
peut-être même avant si le calendrier
politique est respectée et si monsieur
mitterrand appelle monsieur balladur à
l'hôtel de matignon ce que vous
souhaitez car vous êtes je le précise
pour la cohabitation dans l'appareil rpr
vous avez été nommé secrétaire général
adjoint chargé des relations avec
l'opposition
avec les autres partis de l'opposition
ça va pas être une chose très très
facile si on en juge par ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine
alors d'abord il ya eu le dialogue des
sourds de week-end dernier entre
monsieur monsieur jacques chirac et
monsieur giscard d'estaing à un autre
candidat virtuel à la présidence la
république que vous connaissez bien
puisque vous avez dirigé sa campagne
pour l'élection au parlement européen
c'est donc d'abord il ya cette querelle
autour de l'union et de l'unité est ce
qu'il faut en arriver à une formation
unique de l'opposition
ensuite mercredi a eu la mésaventure de
votre candidat commun à la présidence de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur chaban
delmas qui a été trahie au moment du
vote par un certain nombre de vos
députés alors on va commencer par albert
du roy en essayant d'aller au delà de
cette actualité chaude et de comprendre
pourquoi au moment où la gauche
s'effondre et bien la droite
parlementaire n'arrive pas à regagner du
terrain comme jérôme jaffré l'a très
bien démontré dans le monde de cette
semaine
alors après après albert du roy rachid
arhab vous demandera de préciser votre
programme de gouvernement
que ferez vous en cas de cohabitation
que ferez vous en cas de victoire à
l'élection présidentielle et comment
comment vous y prendrez vous et puis
enfin nous terminerons avec jean marie
colombani en parlant un peu de l'europe
et aussi d'autres problèmes français
comme la télévision et un certain nombre
d'autres alors on commence tout de suite
par albert du roy est ce qu'il est
possible avant de répondre aux questions
d'albert dur à dire un mot sur votre
présentation en a moins un mot avez vous
m'avez appelé à parler vrai à essayer en
tout cas mais je voudrais d'abord vous
dire en quatre jours l'opposition a
donné l'image qu'il ne fallait pas et
l'image qu'il fallait l'image qu'il
fallait c'est la rencontre chirac
giscard qui se mettent d'accord sur une
procédure pour les primaires l'image
qu'il ne fallait pas ce sont les
combines de couloirs de l'assemblée
nationale
et l'échec de la candidature de jacques
chaban delmas il vous avez en quatre
jours finalement rassemblé tout ce que
nous ne voulons pas et ce que nous
souhaitons
et finalement c'est une bonne entrée en
matière pour l'émission alors on va
commencer parce que ce qui vous plaît et
vous avez cherché à être convaincant ah
oui on est vraiment au goût du jour
je vous signale que parler vrai ce n'est
pas répondre aux questions avant qu'on
voulait poser mais il répondre
clairement
quand on voulait pose alors ma première
question ne concerne pas encore
l'opposition hier manifestation contre
le racisme paris alors qu'on connaît il
l'a exprimé auparavant
la position du rpr et d'opposition
général par rapport à cette
manifestation je souhaite puisqu'on
parle vrai que nous ne revenions pas
c'est connu la question vous de vos pose
est la suivante vous nicolas sarkozy
quand 70 organisations de gauche
organisent une manifestation contre le
racisme est que cette manifestation
rencontre sujet d'un succès disons
relatif
est-ce que vous aidera vie ou est-ce que
vous êtes désole cette manifestation
pour moi c'est une comédie c'est pas une
manifestation contre jean marie le pen
c'est une manifestation pour jean marie
le pen je ne voudrais pas en vous disant
ça froisser les gens de bonne foi qui
ont été manifestées parce que je suis
certain qu'il ya des tas de gens de
bonne foi qui a été mais j'ai regardé
les images à la division il y avait deux
slogans parmi d'autres
ce vote pour les immigrés abrogation des
mesures marchand telles qu'elles ont été
votés au sénat
vous avez été vous êtes très sélectif
dans le choix de vos slogans l'ain si
vous permettez de répondre très
franchement c'est une comédie si on veut
faire progresser jean marie le pen et
les idées qu'il véhicule
alors continuons comme ça finalement
qu'est-ce que c'est la france
aujourd'hui c'est un certain nombre de
nos compatriotes et bailly d'un côté les
preuves qu'ils regardent d'un côté les
provocations de jean-marie le pen
et dieu sait qu'il n'est pas avare en
provocations et de l'autre le parti
socialiste qui manifeste qui fait des
pancartes et un certain nombre
d'organisations et on a l'impression
qu'ils jouent au ping pong
d'un côté comme de l'autre sans jamais
se parler et pendant ce temps à aucun
moment ne répond aux préoccupations des
français et on traite le mal à la racine
alors moi que cette manifestation et 25
mille ou cent mille personnes ce n'est
pas mon problème je dis que ce n'était
pas une bonne solution et que finalement
si on continue comme ça encore dans ce
pays il faut avoir le courage de le dire
on aura un jean marie le pen à au-delà
de 20% aux prochaines élections alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire quelque est
ce que va faire le rpr contre jean marie
le pen parce qu'après tout c'est un
adversaire aussi pour vous mais il ya
une grande différence voyez-vous le
parti socialiste qui n'a plus projets
remplacent cette absence d'idées projet
en étant contre jean marie le pen à moi
je ne souhaite pas lyon positif le r&b r
qu'est ce qu'il va faire je ne souhaite
pas que les repères se détermine par
rapport au front national
c'est à dire que tous les matins en
prenant notre petit déjeuner on
diabolise le front national et on dit
regardez les injures de jean-marie le
pen
regardez ces violences une bonne fois
pour toutes monsieur du roi est ce qu'on
pourra nous laisser tranquille avec ça
je ne suis pas avec le front national
parce que c'est la haine et que la
france a besoin de paix parce que c'est
la violence et que la france a besoin de
rassemblement et enfin parce que c'est
l'homme du passif de la france mais ce
qu'à chaque élection
à chaque émission on va nous demander
nous justifier vous ne demandez une
solution la seule solution c'est que
l'opposition républicaine et au sein de
l'opposition et pull
républicaine le rpr définissent mieux
son programme et ses propositions je
suis totalement à contre-courant de la
mode en vous disant que les programmes
politiques ne sont pas démodé et qu'il
est venu le temps pour nous de dire aux
français si nous prenons pouvoir voilà
ce que nous ferons et je puis vous dire
qu'on vous trahira pas parce que ces dix
ans d'opposition
peut-être qu'on peut en tirer des leçons
et la première le saut c'est qu'on doit
pas trahir ses électeurs alors dans une
dernière question sur cette
manifestation d'hier les socialistes y
participaient se sont fait conspuer
parce que le gouvernement a pris ces
derniers temps un certain nombre de
mesures notamment celles sur les
fameuses zones de transit
est-ce que sur ces points limitées là
vous convenez que le gouvernement dans
des conditions politiques difficiles
pour lui essaye de faire quelque chose
de positif
ou bien ce que vous rejeter en bloc tout
ce qu'il fait je soutiens la position du
ministre de l'intérieur sous les zones
de transit peut-être faut-il expliquer
d'un mot c'est quoi les zones de transit
vous savez qu'en 1989 la france a
accueilli soixante mille réfugiés
politiques - la dictature dans le monde
plus la france a que de réfugié
politique la même année l'italie en
recevait 4000 et l'angleterre 2000 ya
peut-être quelque chose qui va pas nous
avions proposé à villepinte dans le
cadre du programme de l'opposition qu'on
assigne à résidence tout étranger en
france qui fait une demande de réfugié
politique est temps que sa demande n'est
pas étudiée et n'a pas reçu de réponse
on sait où il est parce que jusqu'à
présent comment ça se passe le réfugié
politique rentrer en france
il peut aller habiter où il veut il
avait même le droit au travail et trois
ans après on instruisait sa demande et
si on la refuse elle ne retrouvait pas
donc cette mesure de zone de transit
pour trois semaines est une bonne mesure
j'ajoute qu'elle n'a pas été voté par
les socialistes au sénat mais seulement
par l'opposition sur ce point le
gouvernement ait eu raison sur tous les
autres
hélas à part des tables rondes rien de
sérieux n'a été mise en place
alors je voudrais qu'on en arrive
maintenant à
là l'état de santé de l'opposition le
françois henri de virieu faisait
allusion tout à l'heure à la mésaventure
au mauvais scores de jacques chaban
delmas là pour l'élection à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
mercredi
qu'est ce qui explique le fait que gros
trentaine de voix de députés de
l'opposition ait manqué ou candidat
unique de l'opposition
si je savais exactement on n'aurait pas
commis cette erreur parce que l'union a
reculé
c'est pas un drame la sphère de de
l'élection au perchoir
mais l'union a reculé qu'est-ce qui les
caisses qui l'expliquent six jours
répondait franchement émeutes est que
dans le foie je me suis moi-même poser
cette question c'est le sens de la
discipline voyez vous que dans nos
formations politiques on comprenne qui
ne peut pas y avoir de succès personnel
sur un échec collectif qu'on comprenne
qu'on est tout seul même bateau et que
si on veut avoir la chance d'appliquer
nos idées au gouvernement il faut que
chacun sache mettre un peu son
originalité au service de l'ensemble et
finalement il ya eu des petites
combinaisons de couloirs alors mangue
manque de discipline évident alors je
voudrais qu'on aille un peu plus au fond
qu'est ce qui a suscité ce manque de
discipline je vais vous donner deux
hypothèses et vous me direz si vous
voulez les retenaient ou pas
premièrement certains ont dit jacques
chaban-delmas 76 ans était pas un signe
de renouvellement il est trop alger il
fallait un jeune deuxièmement certains
autres ont dit certains députés
centristes ou autres souhaite la
constitution d'une espèce de troisième
force à l'assemblée entre la gauche et
la droite
alors est ce qu'il est ce que ces
questions sont valables et ce qu'on en a
d'autres pour moi l'argument de l'âge
n'est pas un argument pour des raisons
biologiques qui vous apparaîtront
certainement je ne suis pas contre les
jeunes mais cette espèce de raciste qui
consiste à dire parce qu'on est jeune on
est intelligent parce qu'on l'ait - n'a
plus rien à faire je ne me reconnais pas
le président la république et ravive et
sachets sachets web enfin je suis pas
content françois mitterrand parce qu'il
a l'âge qu'il a pu mais vous j'ai
attendu pour être j'ai pas attendu qu'il
est ses tâches pour être contre lui et
finalement c'est c'est un des papes
politique misérable au fond qui consiste
à se baser sur l'âge non il ya t'il eu
tentation la troisième force
peut-être peut-être que cette tentation
est récurrente dans une partie de
l'opposition il faut la combattre
je crois surtout finalement que chacun
d'entre nous se sent pas suffisamment
comptable de l'union de l'opposition
c'est facile voyez vous de dire bah
l'union de l'opposition c'est chirac et
c'est giscard et personne d'autre et
bien la preuve a été montré l'autre jour
à cause de la sphère du perchoir que
l'union de l'opposition celle à faire de
chaque parlementaire de chaque maire de
chaque militant et le jour voyez-vous
monsieur du roi où tout le monde a
compris ça ce jour là l'opposition est
en place pour apporter un grand succès
en gros candidats présidents les plus
sérieux de l'opposition jacques chirac
qui a déjà été candidat valérie létard
destin qui a déjà été président candidat
à la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
jacques chaban delmas qui a déjà été
plusieurs fois président un sommet
national premier ministre et c est ce qu
il n'y a pas à la tête de l'opposition
un problème de renouvellement quand même
est-ce que vous êtes bien rendu compte
de ce qui se passe dans le monde
aujourd'hui
ça claque de partout on voit revenir ce
qu'on croyait inimaginable une guerre
moyenâgeuse à 800 kilomètres de nos
frontières
chacun d'entre nous tu es convaincu que
l'europe ne pouvait pas connaître la
guerre des épidémies je pense au sida
chacun d'entre nous considérait que les
épidémies c'était pour des contrées
africaines lointaine et finalement
j'arrive on était dans un atmosphère
politique préserver et la seule chose
qui comptait sur les hommes politiques
qui venaient à la télévision la larme à
l'oeil
la main sur le coeur en disant regardez
comme je suis sincère et finalement tout
le monde d'admirer le discours de michel
rocard premier ministre je vais réparer
les boîtes à lettres et repeindre les
cages d'ascenseur si ce qu'on attendait
avant lui mais mais harlem désir n'est
pas premier ministre en tout cas pas
pour l'instant c'est ce qu'on attendait
les hommes politiques
et puis finalement on s'aperçoit que le
monde est beaucoup plus dur qu aucun des
problèmes qu'on croyait régler mais les
gens d'expérience va donc l'expérience
ça compte
et en ce qui me concerne je n'ai aucun
état d'âme à vous dire moi je
soutiendrai jacques chirac parce que je
pense que pour mon pays profondément il
vaut mieux avoir comme président la
république quelqu'un qui a de
l'expérience
alors bon il ya plusieurs mais est-ce
que ça empêche le renouvellement non en
aucun cas
pourquoi il ya plusieurs présidentiables
de l'opposition il y aura qu'un seul
président il aura théoriquement qu'un
seul candidat
vous avez mis au point un système de
primaires pour éliminer et pour choisir
celui qui vous représentera l'opinion
avait le sentiment que ce système de
primaires il était mis au point depuis
très longtemps que tout était réglé puis
on voit jacques chirac insister beaucoup
en disant il faut d'abord régler le
problème des primaires si les six
tellement quoi ils se méfient ça se
passe pas bien
non il faut reconnaître que ça pas été
assez vite si c'était réglé on n'en
parlerait pas d'abord ma conviction
c'est qu'on n'a pas le choix si on va
diviser la prochaine présidentielle
chacun d'entre nous peut rester à la
maison deere a pas d'élection pour nous
et moi je n'ai pas envie qu'on fasse aux
cadeaux à l'opposition à l'opposition
d'alors si on gagne 1,93 c'est à dire à
la gauche mais ça n'allait pas assez
vite
finalement il ya deux thèses en présence
tout ça est très simple pour jacques
chirac et pour leurs pairs nous
considéraient qu'il vaut mieux faire
confiance à tous les électeurs de
l'opposition et on leur dit choisissez
votre champion c'est les primaires et
nous on s'incline valéry giscard
d'estaing l'udf considère qu'il vaut
mieux faire confiance
un collège électoral plus réduit les
élus on verra ce qu'il en sortira
jacques chirac a fait l'ouverture en
disant on est prêt à discuter des
modalités
ce qu'on veut c'est que le système soit
mise en place et je vous dis avec la
même force mais très tranquillement aux
yeux du roi
moi je me battrai pour que ça soit
chirac mais si ça ne devait pas être
chirac
je soutiendrai le candidat de
l'opposition quel qu'il soit parce que
la priorité pour moi c'est que la gauche
qui sera au pouvoir depuis 14 ans ça
soit fini
si les deux familles de l'opposition ne
se mettent pas d'accord sur la formule
des primaires qu'est ce qui se passe on
n'a pas le choix c'est du roi cela veut
dire que l'opposition a décidé de se
suicider et moi j'ai une partie et moi
et bien d'autres nous ne participerons
pas à ce suicide
il ya ici je les ai invités un certain
nombre de jeunes parlementaires je puis
vous dire que nous notre culture se
diront il faut bien comprendre ça pour
voir cette spécificité c'est une culture
d'opposition
on a connu des combats politiques que
l'opposition serait quasiment que les
échecs y en a pas un d'entre nous à la
can you qui a été ministre et nous on en
a assez et on ne veut pas faire l'union
dans nos circonscriptions pour qu'au
moment des présidentielles ça casse il
n'y a pas le choix
vous me dites qu'est ce qui se passe il
ya pas échec nous rentrerons à la maison
il y aura succès
des primaires parce qu'il n'y a pas de
succès des primaires il rappaz succède
le possesseur certains leaders
expérimentés et est important de
l'opposition disent pour gagner il faut
plus deux mouvements il faut un parti il
faut l'unité entre le rpr et l'udf quel
est votre avis on n'a rien eu un père
est en délire et d'ailleurs on n'a rien
compris au processus de l'union de
l'opposition
si on n'a pas compris que le parti
unique ça peut être un aboutissement
mais en aucun cas un préalable chez moi
quand on construit une maison commence
par les fondations avant d'installer la
cheminée le parti ni qui me fait pas
peur il ne nous fait pas peur mais la
question qui se pose avant de savoir si
on va habiter dans la même maison
au moins qu'on vérifie si on a le même
programme il ya des points encore à
travailler il faut pas raconter
d'histoires il faut qu'on fait avec ça
qu'ils racontent des histoires alors
parce que l'autre jour il disait il ya
une plus que des petits problèmes de
nuances entre nos programmes non mais je
suis pas venu ici pour vous dire que je
suis systématiquement d'accord avec tout
ce que l'opposition compte de
responsables parce que ou alors je suis
venu raconter des histoires il faut
qu'on se mette d'accord sur le programme
l'europe pose problème on en parle il
faut qu'on fasse pour l'europe qu'on l'a
fait pour l'immigration et deuxièmement
qu'on soit d'accord pour désigner notre
champion aux présidentielles qu'est-ce
que ça amènerait pour nous d'inviter
dans la même maison
si aux présidentielles on défend deux
candidats différents absurde
si ces deux préalables programme et
présidentielles sont réglés pourquoi pas
un jour imaginé qu'on habitera dans la
même maison
je suis plutôt pour étant entendu que je
préfère que ça se passe après les
élections alors les prochaines élections
c'est les élections régionales
si comme les sondages l'indiquent le
parti socialiste à dire le parti du
pouvoir réalise un très mauvais score
ils ont inférieur à 20%
est-ce que bien que ce soit des
élections régionales
il vous semble que sa légitimité
nationale sera remise en cause
non
le parti socialiste aura commencé à
recevoir le premier échec d'une longue
liste
mais à 20 % ou moins de 20% il sera
légitime qu'il reste au pouvoir
en ce qui me concerne c'est moi je suis
très respectueux de la constitution et
je ne suis pas pressé les élections
régionales sont là pour désigner des
majorités au conseil régional
c'est au parti socialiste en tirer les
conclusions
mais en ce qui nous concerne nous nous
respecterons les échéances je ne vois
pas pourquoi dans ce pays même si c'est
notre intérêt monsieur du roi et même si
nous tous nous avons envie de mettre en
place nos idées effectivement les temps
au gouvernement
je crois qu'il faut prendre l'habitude
de vivre dans une démocratie police et
républicaine et moi je ne serai pas de
ceux qui le dimanche dans les congrès de
leur parti politique explique que la
constitution est formidable qu'il faut
la respecter et qui à la première
occasion voudrait qu'on dise ah bah ne
faut pas la respecter
élections régionales dans ces régionales
bonne claque pour les socialistes je
l'espère de tout coeur parce qu'ils
l'ont bien cherché et que c'est bien
mérité
il nous restera douze mois pour conduire
le combat des élections législatives et
là se pose le problème de leur
légitimité
une question par laquelle monsieur
sarkozy que je crois répondre vraiment
par oui ou par non
au lendemain des élections régionales
dans un conseil régional où le rpr et
l'udf et leurs alliés naturels n'ont pas
la majorité
est-ce que vous accepterez des alliances
avec le front national
bah oui non non c'est clair mais
pourquoi faut-il que je revienne pour
dernière question à la première non
qu'est ce qui va se passer un mot
peut-être pour expliquer cela
je ne vois pas où est le piège
personnellement dans une région il ya
des régions il y aura pas de majorité
oui merci la proportionnelle merci la
proportionnelle c'est bien ça est ce que
si le président veut faire la
proportionnelle et ce qui veut rendre
ingouvernable le pays comme souvent
ingouvernable à certain nombre de
régions si nous sommes la première force
politique de la région qu'est ce qui va
se passer
eh bien on prendra le pouvoir et ce
n'est pas la première force politique de
se définir par rapport aux minorités on
verra bien ce que feront à ce moment là
les socialistes les écologistes et tous
les autres en ce qui nous concerne est
ce qu'on peut considérer qu'on est
débarrassé de ce problème
il n'y aura pas d'alliance mais pourquoi
c'est pas une question de morale c'est
qu'on peut pas faire d'alliance avec des
gens et qui on n'est pas d'accord sur le
programme
merci albert du roy vous souhaitez que
monsieur giscard d'estaing prennent
position sur ce problème là aussi
clairement que vous venez de prendre
position mais je ne n'ai pas de conseil
à donner à monsieur giscard d'estaing
mais il doit savoir certainement que
finalement la clarté la franchise et
d'honnêteté ça paye toujours bien on
enchaîne avec rachid arhab chef du
service politique d'antenne 2 sur le
programme de gouvernement de la droite
unie que ferez vous dans quel délai et
comment surtout comment le ferez vous si
vous arrivez au pouvoir et puis peut
être aussi vous avez dit tout à l'heure
nous on a une culture de position n'a
connu que l'opposition
il ya des endroits où vous êtes au
pouvoir actuellement par le jeu des
élections locales on pourrait peut être
en parler aussi un peu cachés d'armes
alors tout d'abord qu'en pensez-vous
arrivée au pouvoir vont chômer sarcosine
jours c'est vous arrivez au pouvoir
puisqu'il y à débat au sein de
l'opposition entre cohabitation pas
cohabitation vous même votre sentiment
votre point de vue je regrette ce débat
parce qu'il nous a fait beaucoup de mal
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi il ya
débat vous le dis très franchement je ne
me vois pas comme mais mes amis mais que
pas parlementaires qui sont ici ou mère
allait faire campagne jusqu'au vendredi
soir en disant aux électeurs faites nous
confiance on a un bon programme et les
meilleurs pour diriger la france
le dimanche on empoche le succès et ont
dit aux électeurs français stupéfait et
bailly non on reste à la maison
le problème de la cohabitation voyez
vous il faut pas leur ouvrir aujourd'hui
parce que c'est le problème du président
de la république que chacun des
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent soit
bien conscient d'une chose si on gagne
monsieur rachid arhab en 1993 on ne fera
pas la grève du pouvoir si monsieur
mitterrand considère qu'il est touché
dans son honneur et que la victoire
spectaculaire de l'opposition le trouble
tellement qu'il ne peut pas rester
vous enverrez ravie je serai le plus
heureux s'il ne peut pas parce qu'il ne
veut pas partir c'est son problème c'est
pas le nôtre nous notre problème c'est
de tenir nos engagements auprès de nos
électeurs
d'ailleurs juste un mot c'est tout à
fait faux de dire qu'en 1988
on a été battus à cause de la
cohabitation on a été battu parce qu'on
était divisée
et on a été battu parce qu'un certain
nombre de ministres de jacques chirac
jusqu'à 17 heures le soir était d'accord
avec lui et à partir de 17h aller courir
meeting pour expliquer tout le mal qu'il
pensait du gouvernement moi je ne sais
pas je ne jette l'anathème sur personne
l'échec de l'opposition on a tous une
part mais au moins qu'on comprenne les
leçons qu'il ya en tirer donc on ira aux
responsabilités du gouvernement parce
que la france en a besoin
vous dites on ira vous êtes prêts à ce
qu'une partie de l'opposition seulement
à y gouverne avec monsieur mitterrand
m'écouter si on a un programme commun de
l'opposition des candidat commun de
l'opposition
et vous croyez qu alors que les français
nous ont fait confiance on restera à la
maison
mais comment l'expliquer aux français on
va dire aux français dans notre campagne
disant de socialiste a déjà fait perdre
beaucoup de temps la france et on va
dire il faut en prendre encore 2 oh
c'est pas possible vous le comprenez
bien donc il s'agit encore de convaincre
quelques-uns de vos partenaires de
l'opposition quelques questions rapido
au maire de neuilly avant de parler du
du programme françois-henri rappelez
vous êtes également député du
département le plus riche de france
qu'avez vous fait pour la fameuse
solidarité entre les villes riches de
ville pauvre un débat qui a lieu
quelques années en france
pourtant les bas peu technique dans
lequel on essaie de nous enfermer nous
dirait très simplement je suis contre
tout système de péréquation
le système de péréquation ça consiste à
quoi prendre villes bien gérées pour le
répartir sans qu'on sache comment
et selon quels critères ma préférence
parce que je suis pour la solidarité utt
qu'on revienne sur la définition de la
dotation générale de fonctionnement
c'est ce que c'est que la dgf c'est
l'ensemble des subventions que l'état de
nos communes
moi j'aurais préféré que l'état dise à
neuilly watts ou de ville riche et bien
je donnerais moins de dgf vous en aurez
moins parce que vous êtes plus riches
mais créer un nouvel impôt facettes une
frénésie mesure ainsi drame vous avez vu
ce qui s'est passé chaque fois qu'un
problème se pose en france
frénésie fiscale alors les banlieues
flambe dotation de solidarité
la sécurité sociale a un problème cg la
décentralisation est en panne nouvelle
taxe d'habitation est ce que ceux qui
nous écoutent ça que toute personne dont
la famille un revenu fiscal supérieur à
10 mille francs par mois à compter du
mois d'octobre prochain aura une
augmentation de sa taxe d'habitation de
40 bourses
et encore on a échappé à l'impôt golf
que voulait instaurer monsieur strauss
kahn
je sais pas comment on a pu échapper à
cette frénésie fiscale va provoquer une
révolte dans ce pays
je vous le dis auprès duquel la révolte
de la pole taxe qu'a connu madame
thatcher en angleterre ne sera rien pour
justine que juste une précision sur la
solidarité
si je comprends bien le sens d'autres
réponses vous expliquez à vos électeurs
de neuilly que finalement vous êtes
contre la technique adoptée mais pas
contre la solidarité avec les villes
pauvres
il est normal qu'une ville riches
reçoivent moins de l'état qu'une ville
pauvre il est anormal que l'état pic
dans la caisse pardon de cette
expression pour leur distribuer sans
savoir à qui et comment la solidarité
meirieu oui la péréquation fiscale
non est il normal alors que l'état
cherche à envoyer en province et en
banlieue parfois un certain nombre
d'entreprises ce qu'on appelle la
délocalisation et qui fait tellement
crié descendre les gens dans la rue moi
je suis pour le principe de la
délocalisation et nous ne remettrons pas
en cause les principales délocalisations
mais pardon de remarque simplement
d'abord ya un certain nombre d'employés
et même deux présidents d'entreprise
délocalisé qui l'ont appris par la
terre-mère la télévision c'est comme ça
d'après vous qu'on respecte la dignité
des gens c'est ça le message socialiste
de justice sociale vous avez un mari une
femme qui travaille à paris vous avez
des enfants qui sont scolarisés et tout
d'un coup il explique à ces gens là d'un
grand coup de pied au derrière et puis
vous retrouverez à marseille à
strasbourg à clermont ferrand
sans même avoir le temps de discuter
puis deuxièmement la sphère de l'ena m
l'ena à strasbourg
c'est comme si on mettait l'école des
glénans sur lac d'annecy pas non plus
plus précisément maintenant du programme
de l'opposition en matière économique
tout d'abord je ne sais pas si vous avez
vu à son âge d'expansion cette semaine
qui est assez intéressant qui montre que
les français sont en gros favorable à
l'état providence et au libéralisme il
ya certaines contradictions que des gens
qui se prépare à gouverner doivent je
pense tenir compte les préoccupations
numéro en tout cas reste l'emploi et la
protection sociale sur l'emploi on
s'achemine tout doucement vers les 3
millions de chômeurs on sait très bien
que ni la gauche ni la droite non de
recette miracle essayé nous faire
comprendre comment vous pensé sortir la
france de ce mauvais pardon un mot c'est
pas trois millions c4 il ya deux
millions huit cent vingt-cinq mille
chômeurs + 1 million
malheureuses personnes qui sont un
traitement social du chômage c'est 4
millions
il faut faire attention parce que nous
quand on en parle c'est des chiffres
c'est des arguments c'est des théories
c'est des principes mais celui qui vit
ça celui là c'est un drame pour lui il
n'y aura pas notre politique sociale
monsieur rachid arhab
c'est la lutte contre le chômage il n'y
aura pas de sommeil pour nous il n'y
aura pas de repos notre priorité c'est
cela comment tout le monde le alors et
vous ne savez pas c'est pas exact où le
monde le vert dans la république répète
à l'envi tout le monde le nom le
président lors comment comment comment
l'on est un observateur attentif comme
vous le président de la république a dit
autre chose
il a dit la première année de mon
septennat je créerai un million
d'emplois et son premier ministre
monsieur leroy a dit je me battrai sur
la crête des deux millions la crête est
bouleversée et monsieur roy est retourné
à ses chères études donc on dit pas tous
la même chose il ya trois directions
je perds donc lady rapidement première
direction comment voulez vous que nos
entreprises créent des emplois et il n'y
a que les entreprises qui peuvent créer
des emplois tant que la fiscalité
française et les charges sociales
françaises sont ce qu'elles sont nous
payons le plus de charges en europe
tant qu'on n'a pas compris cela alors on
ne créera pas d'emplois
deuxièmement il faut arrêter l'éducation
nationale systems fabrique à fabriquer
des chômeurs une profonde réforme de
l'éducation nationale est nécessaire
et enfin le troisième point il faut
revoir la rigidité des contrats de
travail
peut-être l'une des lois socialistes les
plus permissives c'est la loi soissons
sur le contrat de travail qui interdit
aux entreprises de faire autre chose que
les contrats de travail à durée
indéterminée tout vaut mieux que le
chômage
on va reprendre votre point un parent
justement au premier point donc la
fiscalité vous êtes de ceux qui disent
baisse de la fiscalité est ce que ça
suffit pour créer des emplois c'est une
condition nécessaire mais pas suffisante
la fiscalité mais prenons des exemples
concrets pour pour ne pas lasser
l'attention des téléspectateurs
un exemple savez vous à combien la
tranche marginale de l'impôt sur le
revenu 56,8 % c'est-à-dire qu'avant
d'avoir fait la moindre dépense d'avoir
engagé le moindre frais l'état vous
laisse un peu plus de 43 % de vos
revenus et à une certaine catégorie et
avoue là
nomura ne la tranche marginale de
l'impôt sur le revenu c'est à dire au
dessus d'eux on considère vous savez un
couple qui gagne 20 mille francs et qui
a deux enfants et où il est dans la
tranche marginale d'impôt sur le revenu
on peut considérer que c'est des riches
savez moi je ne pense pas ou pas de
complexe là dessus en rendant pauvres
les riches eux n'a jamais rendu les
pauvres riches
la frénésie fiscale et quelque chose
d'absurde deuxième exemple les
cotisations familiales
au nom de quoi ce sont les entreprises
qui doivent payer la politique familiale
150 milliards de francs nous proposons
c'est une proposition d'edouard balladur
excellente de supprimer sur dix ans les
cotisations familiales et de l'est
budgété c'est le budget de l'état c'est
la responsabilité de l'état
est ce que c'est possible oui pendant de
la protection sociale un mot là-dessus
parce que je m'attendais ce que vous
posiez la question pouvait pas poser
parce qu'on dit toujours oui demain on
rasera gratis comment vous ferez il ya
un chiffre qui est terrorisant est ce
que les français le connaissent est ce
que vous savez que quel est le deuxième
budget de l'état le deuxième c'est la
dette
on dépense en france plus pour
rembourser les emprunts socialiste que
pour se défendre le budget de la dette
en france est supérieur au budget de la
défense a été multiplié par cinq
ça coûte 160 milliards de francs rien
que les intérêts de la dette
chaque année le vaste programme de
privatisations que nous allons engager
nous permettra d'être consacré au
désendettement de la france hier rien de
plus prioritaires donc on recommence les
privatisations si vous revenez au
pouvoir c'est clair mais les
privatisations tenues partout dans le
monde
d'ailleurs il ya une anecdote amusante
jacques attali est un homme très
intelligent et qu'il mangeait beaucoup
de considération a été le conseiller du
président de la république qui a le plus
nationalisé en france le plus de
l'histoire de la france et on a mis
président de la berd la banque
européenne chargée de conseiller les
gouvernements qui vont privatiser c'est
un spécialiste
vous n'avez pas justement l'impression
que les socialistes et vous vous êtes
beaucoup rapprochés sur tous ces thèmes
là en aucune façon je n'ai pas vu de
grands mouvements de privatisations en
france
considérez vous monsieur rachid a
rappelé que c'est la semi privatisation
récemment n'y a pas de semis il ya pas
de semi privatisation est ce que vous
considérez normal que l'état français
fabriquent des lave-linge produisent des
médicaments produisent des voitures soit
propriétaire d'une compagnie aérienne
savez vous quelle est la seule compagnie
aria
pas beaucoup company a rien qui ait fait
des bénéfices en 1990
british airways privatisée en 1983 est
ce que c'est normal
est ce que vous croyez pas que l'état ne
à faire avec la sécurité avec
l'immigration avec ses fonctions
régaliennes que de perdre son temps
comme ça l'état est un mauvais
actionnaires alors que les compagnies
américaines sont aux avant-postes de
l'effondrement donc c'est pas très
démonstratif scolaire mais cela
permettez moi de vous dire que ça n'a
pas grand chose à voir
c'est un problème de dérégulation je
peux dire mais prenons l'exemple des
compagnies lula sens est la même pour
tout le monde non mais prenons l'exemple
des compagnies aériennes air france pour
redresser sa flotte qui est une des plus
anciennes du monde
en tout cas d'europe a besoin de 5
milliards de francs capital l'état et
son actionnaire a fait une mini
privatisation pour dégager 2 milliards
de francs et on dit au président d'air
france qui n'en peut mais et ben voilà
deux milliards comment ils remplacent
les 3 milliards l'état étape mauvaise
actionnaires vous savez quand on est aux
responsabilités du gouvernement
on a suffisamment de choses à faire pour
pas perdre son temps on a besoin de
privatiser pour que le secteur
concurrentiel soit bien géré et on a
besoin de privatiser
car il faut désendetter la france alors
vous évoquez tout à l'heure parmi les
moyens de lutter contre le chômage
l'éducation là je vous avoue qu'on a
besoin de choses très précises parce que
c'est le flou dans tous les programmes à
gauche comme à droite
quel est votre votre point de vue de
votre première action d'avant sur
l'éducation le premier problème c'est
pas tant ce qu'il faut faire comment on
réforme l'éducation nationale pourquoi
tous les ministres ont échoué c'est une
question qu'on s'est posée pourquoi ça
échoue après tout y est des hommes
intelligents ministe du cassiot national
et nous pensons que la méthode pour
réformer l'éducation nationale c'est la
suivante états généraux dans toute la
france dès que nous arrivons au pouvoir
pour écouter pour discuter pour
comprendre et pour apprendre parce que
l'homme politique doit aussi apprendre à
écouter commission des sages style
commission marc selon pour le code de la
nationalité qui permettra d'établir les
bases d'une loi référendaire
référendaire et référendum parce que la
ferme éducation nationale c'est pas
simplement la sphère des syndicats c'est
la sphère des familles et chacun d'entre
nous et par le référendum nous feront
bouger l'éducation nationale mais que
chacun de ceux qui écoutent se rassure
parce que celui qui veut engager la
réforme l'éducation nationale doit avoir
du courage courage de dire aux
enseignants attention le statut qui est
censé vous
et g on vous ment il vous pénalise
courage de dire aux enfants
indépendamment de votre travail vous
n'aurez rien n'ayez pas peur de la
sélection moi je voudrais un
gouvernement qui parle vrai et dire aux
français dit aux jeunes qui sont dans
les écoles que la sélection c'est la
meilleure garantie de l'égalité des
chances et qu'on leur ment quand on leur
fait peur comme ça
dire aux familles avoir le courage de
leur dire que c'est pas parce qu'on est
dans un bon milieu un milieu aisé que
son fils a le droit de faire des études
supérieures qui a d'autres voies c'est
cet esprit parce que shahram ne vous
trompez pas notre volonté quand vous
revenez hadrons pouvoir c'est d'engager
des réformes profondes dans ce pays a
besoin
nous sommes contre les socialistes parce
que sont les conservateurs et des
immobile ce pays a besoin d'être réformé
et c'est ça notre engagement est
finalement peut-être c'est ça qui fait
que la politique est passionnante
un mot sur les délais sur l'éducation
nationale votre calendrier c'est quoi au
bout de combien de mois vous arrivez au
référendum pour réformer l'éducation
nationale il faut une bonne année de
discussions et une dans la question sur
quels seraient les teintes de ce
référendum
voyez des mots magiques évaluation est
ce que vous considérez comme normal que
ceux qui ont la charge de former nos
enfants à aucun moment ne soient évalués
est ce que vous considérez comme normal
qu'à aucun moment on ne puisse mesurer
l'efficacité
les performances de tel établissement ou
de telle classe autonomie est-ce que
considéré comme normal que le chef
d'établissement n'ai aucun pouvoir dans
le choix de son équipe pédagogique et
dans le choix des matières enseignées
décentralisation est ce qu ont considéré
comme normal que les collectivités
territoriales puissent payer pour
repeindre les classes mais n'est pas
leur mot à dire pour payer des
instituteurs ou des profs
moi je serais pour que le conseil
régional où le conseil général puisse
payer les professeurs qui enseignent
dans des zones difficiles ou puisse
payer des professeurs dans un collège
pendant le collage dans les collèges
dans les lycées et pour les régions dans
les universités si je dois encore une
question françois hory dans tout ce que
vous venez de nous dire y at il une
seule décision du gouvernement de gauche
qui qui vous paraissent significative le
rmi par exemple ce n'est pas celle ci
que j'aurai choisi parce que voyez vous
je ne compte
je ne considère pas que salarié les
pauvres soient forcément la meilleure
décision
finalement s'achète une bonne conscience
mon ambition celle de mes amis il est
tout autre c'est pas de dire aux pauvres
menthe et toi tu as pas eu de chance tu
es sur le bord de la route
tu as pas d'emploi cas pas de maison on
donne un rmi on donne 2000 2500 francs
3000 francs par mois
et puis tu te tais surtout ne nous
embête pas reste dans ton coin
tranquillement notre ambition c'est pas
celle là c'est que tous ces gens qui
sont des exclus qui restent sur le bord
de la route
on leur donne la chance d'avoir un
emploi donc ce n'est pas cette mesure
que j'aurai choisi moi je pense que
l'une des bonnes mesures
c'est l'histoire des emplois familiaux
dont on a exonéré les charges sociales
je regrette le plafond à 25000 francs et
je me pose est d'ailleurs une question
en entendant madame cresson au nom de
quoi on traite moins bien l'individu de
l'entreprise quand une entreprise
emploie des salariés
cette entreprise ne paye pas dans ses
impôts la charge salariale
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi un
particulier qui emploie quelqu'un pour
l'aider une personne âgée ou ou pour
tout simplement pour garder les enfants
je ne vois pas au nom de quoi on
n'aurait pas le droit de déduire la
totalité de ce qu'on paye sont pas des
bénéfices
finalement en france les individus sont
moins bien traités que les entreprises
moi je demande que les individus soient
traités comme les entreprises pas mieux
n'est pas moins merci rachid arhab alors
on va terminer cette émission avec jean
marie colombani pour un quart d'heure
bonjour
après les élections régionales et
cantonales la grande affaire ça va être
la ratification des accords de
maastricht d'ailleurs la grande affaire
du pays c'est la ratification des
affaires de maastricht vous trouvez que
c'est la grande veuille ou non ou apps
l'europe en tout cas alors je vous
laisse un pays où quelque 4 millions de
chômeurs maïs reach escales plus
importants pour l'avenir peut être aussi
pour les chômeurs en tout cas il va se
poser là pleuvra de la rade de leur
ratification
si cette ratification est demandée par
référendum
vous répondez oui où vous répondez non
donc je suis pas du tout l'intention de
répondre aussi brutalement une question
comme cela
malheureusement un référendum c'est oui
ou non non non non moi je dresse du
référendum
écoutez ne voyez pas prétentieux
vous voyez ne voyez aucune prétention de
ma part dans ce que je vous dis mais je
demande que les hommes politiques soient
au moins traitée aussi tranquillement
que le président de la république quand
il est interrogé
on n'a jamais vu ça quand même un
président de la république qui vient à
deux reprises
interrogé par des grands journalistes et
qu'ils ordi taratata vous allez voir
cette année une grande réforme
institutionnelle sur président laquelle
vous verrez bien deux mois après chaînes
concurrentes président la république
taratata vous allez voir référendum
je vais le faire ratifier commandes sur
le président et quand vous verrez bien
alors vous conseille quand même pas
qu'on va se donner le ridicule de
répondre à une question sur une
stratégie s'agissant là président de la
république dont on n'est même pas sûr
monsieur colombani qui sera en mesure
d'engager quelques référendums que cela
soit on est tranquille 1,7 l a5 et la
une
c'était pas sur l'a2 tant qu' il
n'empêche vous même par rapport aux 1 ce
qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir comment
vous situez par rapport à ces accords de
maastricht est ce que vous êtes dans
l'état d'esprit de quelqu'un qui veut lé
ratifier qui veut obtenir leur
ratification
que ce soit par référendum ou par voie
parlementaire ou est-ce que vous êtes
dans l'état d'esprit de certains de ceux
qui sont dans votre groupe par exemple
qui pétitionnent contre ou est-ce que
vous vous situez je me sens également
éloigné des ayatollahs de la
construction européenne qui ont
considéré camail streetg la france
n'avait plus de problèmes et des
ayatollahs contre la construction
européenne qui ont considéré camail
streetg la france s'était défaite maïs
tridge c'est une saab a dans le viseur
phillips gal
on peut par exemple oui mais ça me gêne
pas de vous dire je suis en total
désaccord avec philippe seguin sur sa
conception européenne
ça n'empêche que nous ayons beaucoup
d'autres points communs mais sur ce
point là je trouve que c'était faire
beaucoup d'honneur à maastricht
maastricht c'est un pas dans la bonne
direction
c'est un pas insuffisant pour moi mais
que s'il n'y avait comme streetg qu'il
n'y aurait pas de problème à le ratifier
mais comme vous le savez il n'y aura pas
que maastricht bien voilà une réponse en
tout cas clair la tribu principal de la
souveraineté française un des attributs
principaux ça reste la force de frappe
est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui pensent
que à terme la force de frappe la force
nucléaire française doit s'intégrer à
une défense européenne est ce que la
france
verser au pot commun ce qui est le
diamant de sa défense
ou est-ce que la défense européenne peut
se construire en dehors de tout apport
nucléaire non et oui je pense que la
larme nucléaire devient totalement
inefficace s'il faut l'accord de
plusieurs pour appuyer sur le bouton
si au moment d'appuyer sur le bouton il
faut réunir le conseil des chefs d'état
pour demander à l'unanimité
naturellement alors c'est pas la peine
de dépenser des sous pour l'art
nucléaire chacun peut le comprendre
y compris ceux qui ne sont pas
spécialistes en revanche je suis pour la
remise en cause de la notion de
sanctuaires c'est à dire qu'à un moment
ou un autre
la france comme l'angleterre d'ailleurs
doivent se poser le problème de la
sécurité de l'europe et on ne peut pas
dans le même temps dire les européens
prenaient plus en main votre défense
européenne soyons plus indépendant
vis-à-vis des etats-unis aient refusé
d'envisager selon des modalités qu'il
est trop tôt pour préciser je n'en sais
rien d'ailleurs que l'armé nucléaire
française et larmes nucléaire anglaise
puisse être engagée indépendamment d'une
attaque directe sur notre sol bien tout
à l'heure vous avez fait un vibrant
plaidoyer pour la réforme
en dix ans les contenus associés sont
des conservateurs nous nous serons au
quelqu'un va défendre et par millions
que l'algérie n'a pas cision vous le dis
si plus général de gaulle vous êtes pour
que les américains restent en europe
pour qu'il s'en aille mais merci de
rappeler l'engagement gaulliste à chaque
fois que les is c'était quand même le
retrait de l'otan oui mais non à chaque
fois que les américains à un organisme
directeur intégré à chaque fois que les
américains ont eu besoin des français à
l'époque du général de gaulle le général
de gaulle a répondu présent
souvenez-vous de cuba de gaulle a été le
premier aux côtés des amériques
la guerre du golfe mais peu importe mais
où
oui bon on l'a soutenu le président de
la république oui présent république pas
son ministre de la défense
comme vous en souvenez certainement du
cal
fournier finalement heureusement le
ridicule ne tue plus spécialement aux
politiques se permet de laisser de
l'espoir pour un certain nombre d'hommes
et de femmes politiques sur la question
précise que vous posez moi je
considérais comme un grand dommage que
les américains qui totalement et
complètement le sol de l'europe
les américains sont nos alliés et nos
amis et l'europe a encore besoin des
américains pour assurer sa défense
donc je suis vigoureusement contre tous
les couplages général de le général doit
se retourner dans sa tombe une ans alors
là vraiment ça parce que tu es sûr d'en
dans l'arrêt fleuve plaidoyer réformiste
est ce que vous incluez la justice et si
oui comment dans quelles directions ô
combien la justice est bien malade après
dix ans de socialisme
je voudrais en prendre deux exemples
considérez vous comme normal que le
conseil supérieur magistrature c'est un
mot barbare c'est le conseil finalement
qui gère la carrière des matchs de tous
les magistrats et bien est ce que les
français savent que tous les membres
sans exception du conseil supérieur de
la magistrature sont nommés par le
président de la république
tous ça c'est la constitution de 1952
met donc sur ce point vous mais la
réforme est tout ce que je veux la
réforme et parce que je souhaite une une
justice indépendante
deuxième problème gigantesque et très
difficile les rapports entre les médias
la justice sur colombani ça peut plus
continuer comme ça
les droits de l'homme en france ils sont
pas réservées à quelques contrées
lointaines africaine les droits de
l'homme c'est pour chaque français
moi je n'accepte pas cette idée qu'un
inculpé voit son nom bafouer un inculpé
réputés innocents la personne
aujourd'hui qui est inculpé mais
dites-moi celui-là voit sa vie brisée
brisé avant même qu'on sache il est
coupable c'est pas normal
est ce qu'il faut pour les majeurs faire
la même règle pour les mineurs vous ne
devez pas avoir le droit de citer de
noms dans une affaire judiciaire temps
qu'une juridiction n'a pas prononcé un
juge mais vous comprenez bien dans ces
domaines nous sommes deux jeux d'hier ya
la presse et les magistrats est ce que
vous considérez que les magistrats dans
ce domaine se servent trop du pouvoir
qu'ils ont justement de jeter en pâture
un certain nombre d'hommes politiques
par exemple il faut que je fasse
attention à ma réponse parce qu'il faut
jamais généraliser et on risque de
brusquer de choquer une catégorie de
gens les magistrats qui font bien leur
travail dans des conditions difficiles
mais franchement les médias la justice a
fait pas bon ménage
et je ne comprends pas pourquoi le
secret de l'instruction n'est jamais
respectée
je ne comprends pas comment toutes les
télévisions sont au courant que untel ou
untel est convoqué par un juge
d'instruction
dites-moi quand vous êtes un personnage
public il fait pas bon être convoqué
aujourd'hui par un juge d'instruction
alors comprenez moi bien je suis pour
qu'on fasse des exemples si les hommes
politiques ont fauté des exemples dur
qu'on sanctionne brutalement parce que
y'en a assez que nous autres qui sommes
honnêtes monsieur colombani
on supporte la dignité d'un petit nombre
d'entre nous alors oui pour faire le que
la justice fasse son travail
mais faire le travail de la justice ça
n'a rien à voir avec la publicité
médiatique
mais alors pourquoi dans ces conditions
ce que vous n'êtes pas seuls à tenir ce
discours disant il faudrait il faut
faire des exemples quand il ya des
dérapages personnel pourquoi dans ces
conditions une commission constituée à
l'assemblée nationale pour statuer sur
l'immunité parlementaire d'un député
monsieur phare un député de droite
pourquoi cette commission se séparent
sans trancher cette question de la levée
de l'immunité
je suis est ce que les parlementaires ne
va pas commencer par donner l'exemple
dans ce domaine monsieur colombani
j'aurais été membre de la commission qui
avait à statuer sur la levée de
l'immunité parlementaire de monsieur
boucheron comme de monsieur pharand
j'aurais voté en mon âme et conscience
pour qu'on lève l'immunité parlementaire
de ces deux parlementaires
mais je dis attention moi je ne
participe pas de la chasse à l'homme je
ne sais pas si monsieur pharand monsieur
boucheron sont coupables
ce que je sais c'est que devant les
français on leur doit la vérité est
qu'il n'ya pas d'un d'immunité
parlementaire lorsque des instructions
sont nécessaires j'aurais voté pour par
parenthèse l'immunité parlementaire
aujourd'hui on comprend les conditions
historiques dans laquelle sa a été créée
mais aujourd'hui est-ce que ça encore
une utilité
est-ce que ça n'apparaît pas finalement
aux yeux des français comme un de ces
nombreux privilèges qui sont attachés à
la fonction politique et qu'ils sont
devenu un peu insupportable pour
l'opinion monsieur colombani aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus la même utilité
demain on pourrait la retrouver c'est ça
qui me gêne dans cette question et qui
m'oblige à me donner ma réponse dans un
climat de démocratie apaisée
on n'a pas besoin de ces protections si
demain la france et l'a connu dans son
histoire devait connaître d'autres
moments troublés alors peut-être qu on
sera content que les hommes politiques
soient protégés par cette unité
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
gangstérisme et la malhonnêteté mais
vraiment croyez moi et vous pourriez
interrogé tous les parlementaires qui
sont ici tous les maires qui sont ici on
en a ras-le-bol
on en a ras-le-bol d'être insultée
savent c'est fini maintenant c'est pas
parce qu'on demande aux téléspectateurs
aux électeurs leur voix
on doit accepter de se faire insulter en
permanence les hommes et les femmes
politiques sont des gens honnêtes
monsieur colombani et finalement je
crois que nous avons notre part de
responsabilité
un certain nombre des nôtres on donner
prise à cette campagne en s'excusant de
faire la politique
et y'a rien finalement que moi que je ne
déteste plus que ces quelques hommes
politiques qui viennent à la télévision
la radio pour s'excuser de faire la
politique
s'ils en ont assez de faire la politique
s'ils sont fatigués qu'ils posent leurs
valises sur le bord du chemin on prendre
à leur place on a pu les joindre ces
gens là deux questions encore et puis on
changera de sujets deux hommes aussi
différents que robert badinter et albin
chalandon ont porté les mêmes
conclusions
à savoir que le juge d'instruction en
france aujourd'hui est un homme qui a
trop de pouvoir et ils ont débouché sur
l'idée qu'il fallait un système
collégial à 3 est ce que c'est le type
de réformes que vous relancerez une fut
si vous revenez aux affaires ou bien est
ce que c'est une idée farfelue
à titre personnel je suis opposé à la
collégialité en matière d'instruction
pourquoi parce que finalement c'est une
tendance assez socialiste pardon
monsieur chalandon à ces socialistes qui
consiste à ne pas se rendre compte de ce
qu'est un magistrat le magistrat c'est
quelqu'un qui doit décider ce n'est pas
un conciliateur et vous aurez une crise
des vocations
si vous empêchez le magistrat d'exercer
ses responsabilités
une exception pour moi monsieur
colombani la décision d'emprisonnement
la décision qui prive de liberté un
homme une femme doit me semble-t-il est
une décision collective
pour le reste le juge d'instruction doit
rester seul face à sa responsabilité
c'est finalement la grandeur de son
métier bien toutes ces atouts ce climat
d'affaires et n'est bien sûr de gens qui
ont des problèmes d'enrichissement
personnel bien mais l'essentiel est né
du problème du financement des partis et
des campagnes électorales
il ya une loi aujourd'hui qui est une
loi votée en 90 est-ce que vous pouvez
nous assurer que le rpr par exemple la
l'appliquent et jouer à prendre un
exemple concret vous même vous êtes à la
tête d'une cellule présidentielle
disons d'un petit état major
présidentiel qui est celui de jacques
chirac
donc il vous a fallu des locaux des
bureaux du matériel du personnel bref
une logistique importante parce qu'une
affaire présidentielle ça coûte de
l'argent
comment est elle financée d'abord vous
faites bien déshonneur jacques chirac
n'a pas annoncé sa candidature
et comme vous l'avez certainement
observer les élections présidentielles
sont nos quatre ans se prépare à
l'avance dans ses bureaux du boulevard
saint-germain 150 m² deux secrétaires je
voudrais faire une confidence je suis
bénévole même je ne suivrai salaire de
neuilly vous et de parlementaires aux
aveux de m je vais garder je vais vous
dire les moyens d'être bénévole dans ce
sens là écoutez je vais pas non plus mes
excuses et même après que vous d'être
rémunéré en tant que parlementaire et en
tant que maire sûrement pas merci la
même manière que je ne vous demande pas
moi quand je vois combien vous gagnez au
monde sait ça devient ghriba
extraordinaire on doit en permanence
s'excuser on fait du travail la question
d un peu d'écho chambre haute étant l'un
des finances et je vais y répondent
meilleur très simple nous avons créé une
association
cette association un certain nombre de
cotisants une quinzaine qui soutiennent
l'action de jacques chirac et qui verse
à l'association une cotisation qui est
comme vous le savez déductibles d'impôt
voilà exactement comme nous sommes
financés s'agissant du rpr il ya
maintenant un financement public et
c'est très bien
pourquoi parce qu'il faut que les
français comprennent que la démocratie
ça a un coût et qui n'est pas normal et
qu'il n'est pas anormal que l'état paye
pour que les partis politiques puissent
fonctionner parce que finalement si on
est contre le financement public ça veut
dire quoi
il ya que ceux qui ont de l'argent
qu'ils vont pouvoir faire la politique
c'est ça qu'on veut dans ce pays ça
existe et le suffrage censitaire
on achetait
son mandat finalement et nous autres qui
qui qui avons créé notre maison avec nos
mains finalement et bien heureusement
qu'à des financements
heureusement qu'on est rémunéré
heureusement que les partis politiques
peut exister sinon on ne pourrait faire
la politique que les gangsters ou que
les gens qui sont nés avec une cuillère
d'argent dans la bouche
là c'est pas la conception qu'on a de la
démocratie bien quelques questions pour
terminer rapide sur différents sujets le
paysage audiovisuel français que l'on
dit sinistrés et qui doit affronter en
ce moment là dépôt de bilan de la 5
est ce que vous trouvez normal que dans
les rangs de ceux qui veulent reprendre
cette chaîne de télévision figurent un
homme politique et pas n'importe lequel
c'est un homme bien typés celui là il
s'agit de charles pasqua est ce que
c'est normal vous prenez le problème
quand même par le petit bout de la
lorgnette par un bouchon l'initiateur
blouin le petit bout pour voir quelque
chose oui peut-être mais écoutez
franchement que charles pasqua ait pris
l'initiative pour sauver la 5 je trouve
ça très bien finalement il a obligé les
pouvoirs publics à bouger à votre place
si on permettait je me serais posé une
autre question mais je veux pas que vous
mettiez de l'eau après freddy est ce que
vous considérez vous monsieur colombani
comme normal que pour la première fois
dans le monde y est un écran noir
une chaîne qui fasse faillite et est ce
que vous trouvez normal est-ce que vous
risque est ce qu il semblait normal que
tf1 qui a 40 % de parts de marché ne
gagne pratiquement pas d'argent est ce
qu'on ne devrait pas tous ensemble se
poser la question de cette frénésie de
réglementation qui finit par tuer toutes
les chaînes le paysage audiovisuel
français est malade est malade d'une
hyper réglementation si nous revenons au
pouvoir
eh bien nous aurons comme priorité la
liberté est un vrai service public que
c'est à dire oh ça veut dire tout
simplement qu'on remboursera aux
services publics antenne 2 fr3 les 2
milliards 300 millions qu'on vous a volé
vous savez que l'état décide d'exonérer
de la redevance un certain nombre de
français et ne compense pas ses recettes
d'exonération pour les chaînes publiques
2 milliards 300 millions iliad
ja 2 milliards 300 millions qui sont à
disposition qui existe premier point
deuxième point pour le reste les quotas
de production est-ce qu'on va avoir le
courage dans ce pays de dire que
certains syndicats de producteurs en
font un peu trop et que les quotas
production ajoutées aux quotas de
diffusion
ça ne veut rien dire alors on oblige des
chaînes à produire après on les oblige à
diffuser et nous content de cela on leur
dit mais attention il faut diffuser
entre 19h45 et 22h15
est ce qu'on va se donner le ridicule ou
plutôt arrêter le ridicule de la notion
d'oeuvre française
savez vous qu'un quatuor qui joue d'ubs
et hop c'est pas une création française
parce qu'ils sont moins neuf et que la
fanfare de romorantin ils sont 42 c'est
une création du visuel française bon
franchement vous croyez pas qu'elle
oblige à faire dernier exemple la règle
des 25 %
au nom de quoi l'opérateur qui dirige
une chaîne ne peut pas avoir 25% du
capital moyennant quoi il ya des
combines chacun le sait bien la liberté
parce que je n'ai pas moi au
gouvernement
l'état n'a pas à décider que les
téléspectateurs doivent regarder telle
ou telle émission
le marché ça existe le contentement des
téléspectateurs aussi alors une vraie
chaîne publique avec une mission de
service public est un service privé
libre vous pensez que la télévision peut
être intégralement les vrais la loi du
marché non il ya bien sûr des règles de
déontologie
il ya un certain nombre de grandes
règles à poser mais vous savez bien le
jeu de virieu que quand on pose trop de
règles on ne respecte aucune et que
finalement les chaînes aujourd'hui elles
ont le choix entre une alternative
misérable mourir en respectant les
règles ou bafouer les règles et
continuer à vivre c'est parce que je
souhaite pour la télévision française
d'un mot si c'est possible tout à
l'heure vous avez pris position pour un
référendum en matière d'éducation vous
souvenez que c'est l'opposition qui au
sénat avait bloqué l'extension du champ
des référendum et que si ce référendum
sur l'éducation n'est pas possible c'est
à cause de l'attitude opposition à
l'époque est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
en faveur d'un d'une réforme
constitutionnelle qui inclurait
l'extension du chantier
louis la saisine du conséquence youn par
les citoyens à titre personnel oui
et quel mandat de pour le président de
la république quelle durée du mandat je
réponds à titre personnel sans engager
ma formation politique même ceux qui
sont ici on a des avis différents
comme je suis pour ma part très attaché
à ce que le président de la république
garde tous les pouvoirs qui sont les
siens je considère que dans ce cas il
doit avoir un mandat plus court qui lui
permettent de vérifier un moment plus
régulier sa légitimité je suis donc pour
ma part pour le quinquennat mais
monsieur que vous le double quinquennat
donc non à la parole en revanche je suis
les milliers d'allemands branlant aussi
jean marion je suis opposé à la
limitation des débits nombre de
candidatures mais monsieur se dirigent
juste un mot pour permis n'est vraiment
un mot je voudrais dire à tous ceux qui
nous écoutent que on a besoin qu'il se
passionne à nouveau pour la politique
parce que la politique c'est le dernier
chant aventure qui existe parce que la
politique c'est formidable et que
surtout il ne faut pas écouter les
mauvais prophète qui explique qu'il n'ya
plus de place pour le politique
le politique est de retour la france a
besoin de débat vous pouvez compter sur
l'opposition pour le relancer
voilà et c'était donc l'heure de vérité
de monsieur nicolas sarkozy secrétaire
général adjoint du rpr prochain invité
la semaine prochaine monsieur antoine
waechter et le dimanche suivant
monsieur raymond barre voilà dans 5
minutes le journal qui va vous être
présenté par philippe lefait bon appétit
bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]